Brouhaha de conversations au loin
...
Musique dynamique
-Je suis allée à la rencontre
de quelques éducateurs
et éducatrices,
et des jeunes et des adultes,
entre 12 et 40 ans,
à Paris, porte de Vanves,
dans la 14e,
et place des Fêtes,
dans le 19e,
et aussi le 93, à Saint-Ouen,
et à Epinay-sur-Seine.
...
Le travail des éducateurs
se trouve au coeur
de la prévention de l'enfance.
Ils aident les jeunes en difficulté
et créent des liens.
Dire un simple bonjour,
être toujours présent
dans les quartiers, dans la rue,
dans le local des éducateurs,
dans les familles.
Ils les accompagnent
sur toutes sortes de situations
souvent instables.
Ils sont là
dans les endroits où parfois
il n'y a plus personne.
Un lien sur le temps
qui construit la relation ou pas,
mais qui laisse
une présence de confiance
sur le trajet des jeunes.
...
-Bon, bon foot, les garçons.
-MERCI.
-Entraînez-vous bien.
T'as des nouvelles, toi,
pour ta détection ?
Propos indistincts
Pourquoi ?
-Il va être sanctionné
alors qu'il est blessé.
-D'où t'es blessé ?
-J'ai mal au genou.
-T'as mal au genou ?
Un coup pendant le foot ?
Ca a tapé où t'as mal ?
Tu l'as immobilisé ?
T'as mis de la pommade ?
-Ouais.
-Je te conseille
d'aller voir un médecin.
Prends soin de toi,
d'accord ?
Allez, bon foot, les garçons.
-Je suis arrivé ici
avec encore une grande proximité
d'âge, au final,
avec les jeunes qu'on accompagne,
12-21.
Après, on sait qu'au final,
la prévention spécialisée,
on dit pas à un jeune à 21 ans :
"Maintenant, tu te démerdes."
Donc il y avait des jeunes de 24,
de 25, de 30 ans.
Quand je suis arrivé,
le premier soir
où je me suis retrouvé
tout seul dans le local,
avec des grands
qui me testaient un peu,
pour voir comment je réagissais,
si je tenais la route, tout ça,
je me suis dit : "Waouh,
c'est pas un boulot facile."
Et en fait,
c'est par les actes
qu'on crée la relation
de confiance.
-J'ai un souvenir dans ce bureau,
justement, de mon premier été.
Je suis arrivée en février.
Je me suis retrouvée
seule un long moment.
Mes collègues étaient en vacances,
on n'était que trois,
et des grands qui sont venus,
de mon âge, de 25 ans.
Ils étaient trois, ils se sont posés
dans ce bureau,
et ils ont sorti un couteau.
Ils m'ont demandé
de mettre la main comme ça
et qu'ils fassent
"tac-tac-tac-tac-tac",
donc j'ai refusé.
Mais ça a été compliqué pour moi,
ils m'ont posé des questions
sur ma sexualité.
Donc je leur ai répondu
sur la sexualité en général :
qu'est-ce qu'un orgasme féminin,
enfin voilà...
Mais ça a été
assez déconcertant pour moi.
J'ai tenu,
et quand ils sont sortis,
je me vois transpirer,
j'en pouvais plus,
et j'ai même les larmes
qui sont montées.
J'ai eu peur, en fait,
j'ai eu peur pour moi.
Je me suis dit : "Qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont me faire ?"
Des grands qui sortaient de prison.
Voilà...
J'en ai reparlé aux grands
et ils se rappellent plus.
Ils me disent :
"On t'a pas fait ça, Caro !"
"Si, vous m'avez fait ça !"
"T'as eu peur ?"
J'ai dit : "Evidemment !
"J'ai cru que vous alliez
peut-être me violer, les garçons."
"Vous vous rendez pas compte,
vous me sortez un couteau,
"certains sortaient de prison,
je vous connaissais pas."
Et ils m'ont dit : "On t'a testée,
je pense, pour voir si tu tenais."
En fait, il y a vraiment
tout ce truc de test
qui est vachement important
en prévention spécialisée.
En tant que femmes,
ce qui va être la drague,
ils vont mettre...
Ton CV ?
-C'est là.
-Là-dessus ?
-Oui, s'il te plaît.
J'ai envoyé,
mais je sais pas si c'est parti.
-Mais c'est pas un CV, ça...
C'est pas une adresse mail.
-Si, si.
-T'as beaucoup d'amis ?
-Oui, beaucoup.
-Beaucoup ?
Dans le quartier,
t'en connais plein ?
-Beaucoup, presque tout le monde.
-Et tout le monde te connaît ?
-Oui.
-Et tout le monde connaît Feu Vert ?
-Presque.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on dit
des éducateurs ?
Tes copains, tout ça,
tout le monde ?
-Que ça serait bien
s'ils s'inscrivaient,
mais des fois,
ils sont occupés pendant la semaine.
-Et tu passes les voir,
dans le local ?
-Oui, à chaque fois
que je passe par-là
et que c'est ouvert,
je dis bonjour.
-Je me souviens de toi disant :
"Venir voir les éducateurs,
c'est bien,
"mais ça ne durera pas
toute la vie."
Tu aimerais que ça dure
toute la vie ?
-Oui.
-Tu sais pourquoi ?
-Parce que c'est génial.
...
Brouhaha de conversations
-Si, je pourrais m'occuper sans eux,
mais quand même,
ça me rendrait un peu triste,
d'être sans eux,
parce que des fois,
on passe des bons moments.
Si je leur parle pas
d'un truc d'organisation
ni de faire mes devoirs,
on peut venir ici,
on fait des jeux de sociétés,
un petit goûter
ou des trucs comme ça,
ça me rend heureux.
...
-Je l'ai entendu.
-Cyberharcèlement, bravo.
-On a le cyberharcèlement,
c'est le harcèlement qui se fait
sur...
-Les réseaux !
-Les réseaux sociaux.
-Ca se fait beaucoup ?
-OUI.
-Et face à une personne
qui subit du harcèlement,
vous pouvez en parler
à une personne
de confiance.
Ca peut être qui, cette personne ?
Les parents ?
-OUI.
-Ca peut être les parents,
un professeur,
surveillant, CPE,
psychologue, infirmière...
Il peut y avoir d'autres adultes
de confiance à qui en parler ?
-En fait, madame...
-Ah, ça peut être qui ?
-Vous.
-Mais nous, on est qui ?
-Des profs.
-Non.
-Des assistants !
-Des psychologues !
-On n'est pas des...
-Mais qu'est-ce qu'ils racontent ?
-On est des adultes,
on va commencer par-là.
-Non, c'est la réalisatrice.
-Assistantes sociales ?
-Non, pas assistantes sociales.
-Des prétendantes !
-Donc vous pouvez en parler
à des éducateurs.
Il faut savoir que par exemple,
un éducateur,
comme un psychologue,
comme une infirmière,
comme un assistant social,
sont soumis au secret professionnel,
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
nous confier des choses,
et on va pas aller le répéter,
sauf si on estime
que vous êtes en danger, on sera
amenés à en parler à vos parents.
Mais nous sommes soumis
au secret professionnel.
Je suis jamais tombée
sur un jeune qui dit :
"Ca m'intéresse pas."
Des fois, ils osent pas trop
le dire :
"Oui, je passe bientôt."
Au moins, il sait où nous trouver.
Après, des fois, ça prend du temps.
Je sais que des jeunes ont été
accompagnés cinq ans après.
Le principal,
c'est qu'il nous ait repérés
en tant que personnes ressources,
et si un jour il estime
qu'il a besoin de nous,
il sait où nous trouver.
C'est pour ça que c'est important
de créer du lien,
parce que quand le lien manque,
on a du mal à échanger
avec les jeunes,
et c'est réciproque.
C'est pour ça que c'est important
de consolider,
de renforcer ce lien-là,
qui est un lien d'échange,
de confiance mutuelle,
et le plus difficile, je dirais,
c'est au moment où peut-être
j'ai du mal à comprendre
ce qu'un jeune veut me dire.
Après, ça se travaille
sur la durée,
et c'est pas grave,
on le formule autrement,
on se répète,
on fait preuve de patience.
-Ouais, ouais, ouais, c'est nous !
-C'est nous !
-Qu'est-ce que j'ai dit ?
Les cours ont déjà commencé !
-Le gamin, le jeune,
il en a marre parce qu'à l'école,
tout le monde lui dit ça,
il rentre chez lui,
ses parents lui disent ça,
et quand il est avec moi...
sans faire la part des choses,
je lui dis la même chose,
ça peut pas marcher.
Quels moyens j'ai
pour lui faire comprendre ?
Le moyen le plus efficace,
c'est le temps.
...
-Les enseignants, ils crient trop,
et j'en ai marre, de l'école,
parce que c'est trop nul.
Ca me saoule.
Ma mère me crie dessus
quand j'ai des mauvaises notes.
Moi, j'aime pas la rendre énervée.
-Qu'est-ce que vous avez envie
de faire, plus tard ?
-Moi, footballeur.
-Moi, si j'arrive pas à percer
dans le foot,
si j'arrive pas à gagner
des sous dans le foot,
je vais essayer
d'être architecte ou ingénieur.
J'ai toujours eu hâte d'avoir
une carte bancaire.
Quand je demande des trucs
à mes parents,
à chaque fois, ils disent non.
Du coup, j'ai hâte d'avoir
une carte bancaire,
de travailler, comme ça,
j'aurais beaucoup de kichta,
comme on dit,
et je pourrais m'acheter
tous mes plaisirs.
-Il y a une chose
qui vient juste de t'arriver.
Ca peut être dans le malheur
et dans le bonheur, tu vois.
Et tu vois un animateur
que t'aimes bien,
tu lui fais confiance,
tu vas lui dire.
Par exemple, tu vas rentrer
dans une salle,
ils vont te dire
d'enlever la capuche...
Ils vont pas te laisser dire
des gros mots,
plein de choses.
La vie.
Moi, j'ai trois projets.
D'abord, mon plan A : rappeur.
Si ça marche pas, j'ai un plan B,
c'est acteur.
Si ça marche pas, plan C : boxeur.
-Je pense que ce qu'il a voulu dire,
par rapport à notre discussion,
c'était de parler de l'avenir
et être capable de se projeter.
Le fait de voir ça
chez des très jeunes, déjà,
qui sans même savoir
ce qu'ils veulent faire
savent ce qu'ils veulent être,
et entre guillemets,
être du bon côté de la barrière,
à cet âge-là,
c'est déjà très important.
*Musique rap
*...
-Là, vous êtes relous,
je vous assure.
Propos indistincts et rires
...
-On dirait qu'on est
des mendiants.
-Dans la manière
où ils se présentaient à nous,
je savais
qu'ils étaient là pour nous,
qu'ils pouvaient nous écouter,
et nous aider dans plein
de domaines.
-Ma manière
de réfléchir, je pense,
grâce à eux, qu'elle a changé,
niveau maturité.
Niveau maturité, je pense
que ça a changé.
Avant, j'étais un gamin.
Mais là, depuis, je me comporte
un peu plus comme un adulte.
Et en vrai, je suis content,
c'est mieux.
-En fait,
c'est pas
avec le temps, je sais pas
comment expliquer.
C'est au fur et à mesure
qu'on comprend ce qu'ils font
comme métier.
Ils se mettent dans notre peau.
Ils nous mettent à l'aise,
aussi, les éducateurs.
-C'est le premier séjour
qu'on fait avec eux.
On a proposé de partir 3-4 jours
dans le château de Feu Vert.
Ils sont un peu fatigués,
vu qu'ils dorment pas trop la nuit,
mais ils ont pas fait
trop de bruit, cette nuit.
Quand on les entend parler,
on apprend des choses.
Quand ils nous parlent,
quand on est posés
pendant des heures ici,
ils s'ouvrent.
Avec eux, on travaille aussi
les gros mots
ou la façon de se comporter
quand il y a des éducateurs
ou quand il y a d'autres personnes.
Et là, je sens par exemple
que le travail avance.
Au tout début, il y a un an,
c'était pas du tout comme ça.
Les gros mots, ça fusait.
Ils sont dans une bulle
et se rendent pas compte
du regard des gens
ou de ce que les gens
peuvent penser.
Ils font plus attention à ça.
Ils grandissent, aussi, mais il y a
aussi le travail qu'on a fait.
Vrombissement de l'aspirateur
Regarde, tu fais ça.
Après, clac, tu coupes, et après...
Inaudible
-Je t'explique.
Tu détaches,
après, tu colles ici, tu colles,
tu colles, tu colles,
tu viens ici,
tu fais le tour,
et tu refais un tour.
C'est excellent, ça.
-Ce que j'ai toujours trouvé
exceptionnel,
chez ces jeunes, même adultes,
c'est cette capacité à rebondir.
Ils ont une espèce de...
Et puis de dédramatisation,
où rien n'est grave, en fait.
Tout peut être pris à la rigolade.
Tu le vois dans leur rapport
entre eux,
ils se chambrent beaucoup.
Ca, c'est aussi assez culturel.
C'est souvent mon discours de dire :
"Je veux pas que vous deveniez
quelqu'un d'autre,
"ni que vous me serviez la soupe
en ayant l'attitude parfaite
"d'un enfant sous cloche,
mais c'est plutôt
"d'aiguiser votre intelligence
de sorte d'être adaptés
"à tout ce qui vous entoure
pour pas que la société
"vous sorte de ses rangs en disant
que vous êtes inadaptés,
"parce que là, du coup,
tu vas pas pouvoir prendre la place
"que tu souhaites prendre.
L'idée, c'est que tu puisses
"réaliser tes rêves,
prendre la place dont tu rêves
"en fonction de tes compétences
et rien n'est trop beau pour toi.
"Par contre, il faut accepter
de jouer avec les codes."
Musique douce
...
-Je leur en ai pas encore parlé,
mais...
On n'en a pas parlé, mais j'aurais
bien repris les deux mêmes.
-Ca a bien fonctionné.
-Oui, ça a bien...
-Valoriser un peu...
-Ca a bien fonctionné.
En plus, c'est dans les locaux
de la mission locale,
c'est le même prestataire.
C'est intéressant
de remettre les deux.
Après, faut qu'on en parle
en équipe.
Propos indistincts
...
-Les adolescents,
ils ont un mouvement de vie,
ils sont fragiles,
mais ils ont une pulsion de vie
très forte.
Et donc ils expriment des choses
à l'état brut.
A leur contact, j'apprends.
J'apprends, effectivement,
que c'est une période
où on peut être fragile
sur tellement de points,
et que c'est important
de pouvoir les comprendre,
de pouvoir leur laisser leur chance,
de pouvoir les accueillir
dans notre société.
C'est les adultes de demain.
-45 secondes, juste ça.
Je ramène au visage,
passe ta hanche,
décolle de ta longe
en barrière.
Regarde comment je suis,
de profil.
-Effectivement,
pas mal de gamins :
"J'aime pas l'école...
"je m'ennuie.
"Je vais au fond de la classe,
je bavarde, je dessine...
"De toute façon,
j'aime pas la prof.
"Je sais pas ce que j'y fais,
à l'école.
"Qu'est-ce que ça va me rapporter ?"
Et c'est vrai qu'on se pose
même plus la question.
On est là dans...
"Il faut que t'ailles à l'école.
"De toute façon,
elle est obligatoire."
"Pourquoi je suis obligé ?
Pourquoi on doit bosser, adulte ?
"Pourquoi...
"il faut pas tricher ?
Pourquoi...
"Pourquoi ma vie est définie
à l'avance ?"
-Va moins vite, la qualité,
pas la quantité.
-Donc l'idée, c'est aussi
de les aider à se définir eux-mêmes,
en termes d'identité,
en termes de :
"Est-ce que ma place est ici ?
"Est-ce que ma place
est dans les voyages ?
"Auprès des autres ?"
Et on leur fait souvent...
comprendre, dans notre discours,
que les armes, elles passent
par la scolarité.
Le système a été conçu comme ça.
-C'est cette importance de mots,
en fait,
où déjà, ils peuvent vriller
d'un coup.
On le voit dans le milieu scolaire,
où des professeurs vont dire :
"Là, t'as été bête."
Alors ça, le jeune, il explose.
C'est vrai que c'est important,
les mots qu'on emploie.
-Il y a pas mal d'adolescents,
quand ils ont des carences
affectives de l'enfance,
dont je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils ont du mal à accepter
que quelqu'un puisse être là
pour eux.
Et ce que je trouve passionnant
dans ce métier,
et à leur contact, c'est
qu'on arrive à un moment donné,
et ça prend énormément de temps,
avec des jeunes comme ça,
- après, ils sortent pas tous... -
qui ont des fragilités,
c'est qu'ils nous demandent
énormément de preuves d'amour.
-Lève ta main droite.
-Aie confiance, sois pas crispé.
Plus t'es relâché,
plus t'es en mouvement.
Tu t'en es rendu compte, continue.
Allez, lâche pas.
Ouais, bien joué, la flexion.
Descends un peu plus.
Tu vois, t'y arrives !
-Quand je considère
que c'est réussi,
c'est quand je me rends compte
que relationnellement,
si tu veux, j'ai passé
une étape avec la personne
qui fait que la personne
a réellement confiance en moi.
-C'est de la bonne fatigue.
-Comparé aux dernières séances,
là, c'est mieux.
Plus on passe les semaines,
plus on commence à faire des trucs
qu'on apprécie mieux.
Comme t'as dit, la confiance,
on a fait un travail sur nous,
on se parle, on fait confiance
aux autres.
C'est mieux, on commence à avancer,
c'est bien.
Il faut qu'on continue comme ça.
-Les jeunes, par exemple,
quand on les accompagne
dans une démarche,
ils aiment nous tenir informés
de ce qu'il en est.
Au fond de moi, de mon petit coeur,
je suis tellement contente pour eux.
Je le montre peut-être pas :
"Je suis contente pour toi."
Mais au fond de moi, je me dis :
"Petite victoire."
Parce que je l'ai accompagné,
j'ai su le remobiliser
quand il se démobilisait.
Je l'ai jamais lâché, j'ai mis
des coups de pied aux fesses :
"Tu vas y arriver,
je suis derrière toi."
Et quand le jeune arrive en disant :
"J'ai mon diplôme",
je suis contente.
Si on n'avait pas été là,
ils seraient peut-être pas allés
au bout, parce qu'ils avaient besoin
de quelqu'un qui les pousse
et souvent, c'est des jeunes
qui ont pas perdu confiance en eux,
mais pas loin.
Là, il faut que je voie,
en premier...
Quelle école tu veux,
en premier ?
Quelle école tu veux, en premier ?
Si tu as le choix ?
-Euh, ben Ferrandi, direct !
-1 : Ferrandi.
-Fouquet's et Ferrandi
sur mon CV...
-OK, 1 : Ferrandi.
En 2 ?
-Il y a des choses
que je peux pas dire à ma mère.
Je passe par Léa, directement.
Après, elle peut me donner
des petites idées
qui font que...
Enfin, pas des idées.
Plutôt des conseils.
Comment je peux en parler à ma mère.
Des fois, elle en parle elle-même
directement à ma mère.
C'est comme une grande personne...
C'est comme si c'était
une personne de ma famille,
à qui je faisais confiance.
-En fait,
ils nous mettent en confiance,
comme ça on a une relation
de père, fils, fille, mère, fils...
C'est qui fait
qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui,
on écoute un peu mieux,
je pense.
On écoute facilement,
sans peur.
Genre, on peut pleurer devant eux,
on n'aura pas de gêne.
-Par exemple, on va jamais aller
dans une ferme...
faire des trucs avec des animaux.
Ca, avec Feu Vert, on est parti...
Par exemple, on va jamais se dire :
"On va faire une distribution
pour les SDF."
Avec Feu Vert,
ils nous montent vers le haut.
-La soupe, on va l'accrocher,
les minettes.
Une fille chante.
Envoie les duvets,
je les mets ici.
Eh, donnez pas vos manteaux.
Là, à partir de maintenant,
vous ouvrez vos yeux !
Celles qui sont à gauche
regardent à gauche.
Celles qui sont à droite
regardent à droite.
Quand on voit un SDF,
on s'arrête en speed, là,
et on distribue.
-C'est sympa...
-Wesh, Sonia, wesh...
-Oh, tu parles mal !
-Oooh !
-Oh là là, c'est pour vous !
Oh là là !
-Ben, ça va, oui,
mais à un moment donné,
c'est un budget, aussi,
pour nous, Feu Vert.
J'aimerais bien... On leur fait
des petits pavés de saumon,
ça, j'entends bien, les filles,
mais... faut être aussi réaliste.
On fait avec ce qu'on a.
-C'est quoi, ce chantage ?
Attache-toi, je te dis !
*Musique afrobeat entraînante
-At... tache... toi !
-Elle est attachée.
-Non, toi !
*"Marchand de sable", Vegedream
-OUAIIIIS !
-QUI VOILA ?
C'EST VEGEDREAM DE GAGNOA
QUI VOILA ?
MAIS DIS-MOI QUI VOILA ?
Elle chantonne sur la musique.
*-Mais dis-moi qui voilà ?
Tu n'me crois pas tu dis wallah
A 225 % on t'couche
Et tu fais l'malin
Et j'te fais du sale
Ta meuf j'la fais danser
T'es toujours dans le noir
Tu recherches le soleil...
-Les paires de gants,
faut pas les mettre dedans,
faut les mettre ici.
-On y va, les garçons ?
-Des vrais tours, les gars !
Arrête de couper.
Ca va ?
Attention, c'est pas grave...
J'ai vécu des tas de choses,
en termes de suivi.
Harcèlement scolaire, viols...
J'ai accompagné plein de jeunes
à Bobigny...
Prison pour mineurs, prison...
La génération est peut-être
un peu moins violente...
Mais on a eu des situations...
Les voitures de policiers...
Les jeunes en... en masse,
en groupes, qui...
Qui allaient au niveau du pont,
au niveau du collège,
mais on a eu des choses...
Des fictions, quoi.
Aujourd'hui, non.
Mais moi je dis :
c'est une bombe à retardement,
ce conflit de quartier.
Le même qu'il y a aussi
avec La Source...
Les Presles, pardon.
C'est une bombe à retardement.
Aujourd'hui, il se passe rien,
mais demain...
Mais c'est vrai que ça fait
un petit moment
où des faits très graves,
coups de marteaux, de machette...
Attention !
Ah oui, des choses...
Ici même, dans ce local,
pour l'anecdote,
il y avait des jeunes,
scolarisés au lycée Feyder,
qui est...
plus vers La Source-Les Presles.
Donc les jeunes, largement,
étaient amenés
à s'y rendre en transports
en commun.
Et il y avait un conflit
avec les jeunes du centre-ville
qui les attendaient dans le parc,
à côté.
Un jour, ils se sont fait agresser
avec des machettes !
Un jeune s'est fait couper
la moitié d'un doigt.
J'ai rassemblé tous les jeunes ici,
au local, ici.
J'ai fait... A l'époque,
les CPE du lycée étaient venus,
et on les a réaffectés ailleurs.
-4 buts !
-5 !
-La prochaine fois qu'on vient,
on fait un match avec eux,
vous jouez et on partage
un bon moment ensemble.
Ce serait bien, non ?
Et je vous conseille.
"Tu fais ça, tac, tac, tac !"
Ca travaille votre esprit
de solidarité et de partage.
D'accord ?
On fera ça ?
On y va, les gars !
Musique légère
...
-C'est mieux
d'aller à Feu Vert
que de rester au quartier.
Au quartier, des fois,
y a rien à faire.
Tu peux...
Tu peux avoir des problèmes,
tout ça.
J'ai pas envie d'avoir ça, moi.
J'ai envie de rester à Feu Vert,
pas faire de conneries,
pas avoir de trucs bizarres
avec la drogue, tout ça...
-Parfois,
même si on n'est pas dans ça,
à force de traîner avec des gens
qui sont comme ça,
nous aussi, on va le devenir.
-Faut pas faire de gâchis.
C'est pas juste que tu vas
la découper, la mangue.
-Tu fais comme ça...
Réactions étonnées.
Comme ça... Comme ça...
-Après, tu l'ouvres comme une fleur.
-Voilà !
-C'est comme ça que je fais,
moi aussi.
Rires
-Quand t'épluches, tu laisses pas
ton doigt à la fin.
Sinon, tu peux te le couper.
Tiens, après,
il y a les ananas.
Elles parlent en même temps.
-"Il n'y a que les faiblesses
qui pleurent."
-"Que les faibles".
-"Que les faibles qui pleurent."
-Les faibles !
Rire
-Non, y a pas que les faibles
qui pleurent. Moi, je dis non.
Par exemple, si...
Quelqu'un de dur,
ben, il peut pleurer pour un décès
ou un truc comme ça, mais...
Ca veut pas dire qu'il est faible.
Enfin, si, mais...
Non.
Oh, oh là là...
-Mais est-ce que pleurer,
c'est forcément
une preuve de faiblesse ?
-Non.
-Ma mère,
elle va me dire un truc,
et je vais pleurer.
Genre, ça se fait pas, tout ça.
Après, elle va dire :
"Pourquoi tu pleures ?
C'est pour les faibles !"
Du coup, après,
j'arrête de pleurer.
-Donc ça t'aide ?
-Ouais.
-C'est sa manière...
De te le dire comme ça,
c'est sa manière de te réconforter.
Et ça t'aide ?
-Non.
Enfin, genre, j'arrête de pleurer,
mais sinon, non.
-Ben, j'ai appris les avis
des autres,
comme quoi,
mon avis peut être négatif.
Genre, j'ai su contrôler mes avis
et avoir les autres avis des gens
et tu te donnes un autre avis.
Et c'est ça qui te fait...
Le fait...
Tu peux avoir d'autres avis...
Tu peux te dire que, comme quoi,
t'avais pas raison.
Et tu réfléchis, en fait,
dans ta tête.
-Ca nous aide, ça nous fait avancer.
Et ça m'aide, par exemple,
à avoir...
par exemple, une autre mentalité.
-Hé !
On y va ?
Vous commencez à monter, là,
direct ?
Et puis les autres, on va attendre.
Une fiction,
c'est pas juste une fiction.
Ca peut être la réalité.
Il suffit que tu sois
au mauvais endroit,
au mauvais moment, tu peux finir
comme le garçon dans le film.
Ce qui m'inquiète, c'est la haine
par rapport aux quartiers,
Super M ou Orgemont. J'espère
qu'on n'en arrivera pas là.
Mais pour ça,
il faudra agir avec intelligence.
Mon objectif, avec vous,
l'influence que je peux avoir,
c'est de vous tirer vers le haut.
Vous passer des messages.
Car malheureusement,
ça durera pas toute la vie.
Après, vous allez être des adultes,
des hommes
et, je l'espère pour vous,
de bon gars.
Et vous l'êtes déjà.
Donc tout ce qui peut
vous tirer vers le bas,
conflits de quartier,
"vas-y, va faire le guet",
c'est-à-dire le guetteur,
dans le quartier,
pour le trafic, tout ça...
Eloignez-vous de tout ça, les gars.
L'ado marmonne.
Je sais que c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire, attention !
J'en ai vus, dans le quartier,
qui l'ont fait.
Et des gars comme vous.
C'est-à-dire sans problèmes,
intelligents...
Après, on a tous des problèmes.
Mais qui étaient pas faits
pour ça. Mais ils l'ont fait...
par manque de moyens, de travail...
Donc faites attention à ça,
d'accord ?
Fais attention à toi, Idris.
Junior ? Parle à papa et maman,
tout de suite.
Idris, pareil.
Denis, fais attention à toi.
-Ma mère, elle connaît le Feu Vert.
-Oui, mais tu lui parles du séjour,
s'il te plaît.
Je vais te donner les infos
via WhatsApp. OK ?
-Quand on part en séjour,
tout de suite,
ils veulent mettre leur musique.
Je leur dis :
"OK, je vais mettre vos musiques,
mais je mets les miennes d'abord."
Là, c'est : "Non, tu vas pas
nous mettre tes vieilles musiques !"
"Si, on fait un échange."
C'est marrant.
Et une fois, on a fait un séjour
avec un groupe mixte,
avec des jeunes filles qui avaient
déjà fait un séjour avec moi.
"Tu vas nous remettre du Piaf ?"
"Ben t'as retenu le nom, déjà !"
C'était assez... Donc on échange.
Ils nous apportent
beaucoup de choses,
et on leur apporte beaucoup aussi.
C'est le but, aussi.
Le but des séjours,
c'est de travailler aussi...
Enfin, c'est toujours court,
les séjours, en même temps.
-Ce qui m'énerve,
c'est qu'elles regardent pas.
Mais bon,
elles sont pas aveugles.
-Mais elles vont regarder
une ou deux fois,
et dire "c'est toujours pareil".
"C'est toujours pareil,
c'est bon, on a déjà vu !"
-Ca va ?
-Je sens plus mes pieds, Nassira.
Je veux arrêter.
-Tu fais une pause ?
-Oui.
-J'appelle Karima, là.
Hé, les filles,
rangez vos portables.
Pendant qu'on va à la fromagerie,
vous aurez le temps
de "tac-tac-tac".
-Moi, j'y vais pas.
-Tu restes dans le camion.
Meuglement
Musique douce
...
-C'est pas
parce qu'elle veut faire un truc,
elle laisse les 5 autres
ne pas vouloir faire et elle fait.
-On lui dit "on veut pas faire"
mais elle veut.
On n'a qu'à rester à la maison,
elle vient un autre jour
et elle ramène son fromage !
-On s'est senties forcées.
-Oui, voilà.
Là, c'est vraiment forcé, en fait.
-Ca m'a dégoûtée du fromage.
-Voilà. Et du lait.
Elle rit.
Parce que les vaches,
elles sont hyper sales,
ils les lavent jamais !
-Mais c'est un truc,
dans tous les cas,
qu'on voulait pas faire.
-Mais bon...
C'est fait, c'est fait, hein.
-T'as fait beaucoup la tête, Lina,
aujourd'hui.
J'ai vraiment l'impression que,
cette visite-là,
c'était une torture, pour toi.
Tu t'es forcée.
Donc dis...
Exprime-toi, Lina.
-Ben moi, je voulais pas partir,
dans tous les cas.
-Oui, on avait compris.
Mais on aurait fait quoi ?
On part visiter la fromagerie,
je t'aurais laissée...
-Nous 4, on n'a pas voulu y aller.
-Pourquoi hier,
vous m'avez pas dit ça ?
Vous avez dit : "C'est chouette,
si on fait la traite des vaches."
-"Si on fait la traite des vaches."
-Vous auriez fait comment ?
-Si j'aurais vu que les vaches,
elles sont comme ça,
je les aurais même pas touchées.
-J'étais pas très contente.
Un séjour, c'est aussi du ski,
vous vous êtes fait plaisir,
de la luge, mais je tiens
aux parties culturelles.
Ils vont parler
de leurs familles, de difficultés,
ils vont parler de...
Voilà, il y a des choses difficiles
à entendre, aussi.
Il y a des révélations,
des fois, comme ça.
Des fois,
on n'est pas toujours prêts.
Voilà... Donc du coup...
Attention à bien écouter
pour reprendre ça, après.
-Viens !
"Tsk-tsk !"
-Avec Clémence,
j'ai trouvé plein de trucs,
en fait.
Des trucs vraiment sincères.
Et du coup,
elle avait le côté professionnel,
mais plus...
dans la vie réelle, en vrai.
Elle donne des conseils,
elle a des façons
pour parler aux jeunes,
et elle m'a montré comment...
comment est la vie, en vrai.
Des fois, même, quand j'étais
dans la difficulté, tout ça,
même le soir, tard,
elle est là, elle me répond.
Et après, ses réponses, c'est bien,
c'est doux, c'est compréhensif,
c'est...
C'est des mots qui rentrent vraiment
dans la tête.
C'est pas comme n'importe qui que...
quand je leur raconte,
c'est pas la même chose.
Et moi, quand je vois le...
comment elle est, Clémence,
j'aimerais bien avoir une vie
comme elle, en fait. Vraiment.
Dans le sens, comment elle présente,
comment elle parle,
comment... ses manières et tout ça.
Vraiment.
-Ben, cette séance,
c'était pas comme la première.
Mais elle m'a appris des choses,
par contre.
-C'est pour ça que...
J'aime bien te laisser, aussi,
réfléchir et...
Pas tout de suite débriefer et...
Parce que ça s'infuse,
et dans ton corps,
ça s'infuse aussi.
Comme une infusion... à la cannelle.
Elles rient.
-Je l'aime trop.
Vraiment.
Malgré...
J'étais chiante, avec elle.
-Alors moi, dans mes formations,
on n'en a jamais parlé, bien sûr.
Il est pas question d'amour,
il est question de transfert.
Le transfert,
c'est une grande question d'amour,
mais rarement, on va t'en parler
en ces termes-là parce que...
C'est comme un gros mot lâché,
comme une bombe où on parle
d'émotions, d'affect...
Non, surtout pas.
Et c'est quand même fou,
parce que t'arrives avec un tas
de bagages en tant qu'éduc,
et on t'a jamais parlé
de l'essentiel.
Et c'est... J'ai l'impression,
comme dans l'éducation
avec les enfants,
ou par exemple, la sexualité.
Et on n'en parle jamais !
On n'en parle
qu'en termes de maladies,
en termes de prévention des maladies
et de la grossesse, éventuellement,
et puis fin de l'histoire.
-Bien ?
-Ca tombe bien, toi.
Ca y est, t'as eu ta paye ?
-Ouais, vas-y.
-Tu l'as eue, ta paye ?
-Oui, mais laisse tomber...
-Mais tu l'as eue ?
-Oui, c'est carré.
-T'as pu te faire un resto ?
-Même pas, j'ai payé mes factures.
-C'est bien que t'aies payé
tes factures plutôt que le resto.
Tu passes quand me voir ?
-T'es là demain ?
-Oui.
-A quelle heure ?
-J'ai quelqu'un à 15 heures.
Si tu veux, tu passes
vers 15h30-16 heures, grand max.
A 17 heures, je suis partie.
-Je passe à 15h30.
-15h30, et je t'aide
dans les démarches.
Vas-y, on fait comme ça.
T'as de la sauce.
Je le dis pour toi.
Après, on va te tailler.
-Mon but à moi,
c'est pas d'agir forcément
sur une situation marginale,
ou que moi, j'estime marginale,
déjà,
et pour qui ?
Pour moi ? Pour Pôle emploi ?
Pour la sécurité
de l'arrondissement ?
Il y a des jeunes
qui font des choix,
qui assument leurs choix,
qui savent qu'il y aura,
dans cette direction,
une case prison à un moment donné,
et qui sont pas prêts à changer.
Est-ce qu'un jour,
ils auront une rencontre amoureuse,
et ils décideront
de s'investir davantage
dans leur rencontre amoureuse
qu'auprès de leur groupe de pairs,
dans des codes de la rue ?
Ils seront...
Ils seront décisionnaires.
Je...
-C'est pas toi
qui vas amener ce changement ?
-Peut-être, j'en sais rien.
Mes paroles peuvent avoir écho
dans son esprit
sans même que je le sache,
sans même que lui ou elle le sache.
-Quand tu vas voir en détention,
par exemple, c'est un exemple,
un jeune,
tu vas le voir à un moment donné
où il est dans une fragilité
extrême.
Quand tu vas faire ce mouvement-là,
alors que t'es pas de la famille,
d'aller les voir
et de leur montrer par ton regard
pas que...
Toi, t'es pas de la justice,
mais que t'es encore là pour eux.
T'es encore là pour les écouter,
pour parler avec eux,
parce que tu les apprécies.
Et bah là...
Pour moi, c'est vraiment le rôle
de l'éducateur de prévention.
Nous, on a un rôle à jouer
là-dessus.
C'est que nous,
on peut aller aux interstices,
aux endroits
où il y a plus grand monde.
L'alarme de la porte sonne.
-Sans Feu Vert,
sans Rachid, Aissatou, Romain,
je sais pas Feu Vert en entier,
mais l'équipe qui nous a suivis,
je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui,
je serais en formation,
mais en prison, ou en train de faire
des bêtises encore, moi.
-Et là, maintenant, tu fais quoi ?
-Là, en ce moment,
je suis en formation en alternance,
avec la RATP,
pour devenir conducteur de bus.
-Ils veulent pas
nous décevoir.
Ils savent qu'on va pas les juger,
mais ils veulent qu'on garde
une image positive de leur personne,
et ça, c'est normal,
et ça, c'est humain,
mais il faut prendre le temps.
J'ai pas besoin de tout savoir,
ça m'intéresse pas du tout,
mais c'est vraiment
de les accompagner.
Ils savent qu'on est quand même
des professionnels,
donc du coup, quand même,
on a un oeil assez aiguisé
de qui fait quoi,
et puis du coup,
on sera toujours là pour eux.
On n'est pas là pour juger
qui que ce soit,
mais pour accompagner.
Tu devrais garder le maillot
du Stade Rennais, quand même.
-Il est en dessous !
D'abord, on chauffe un peu.
-Il faut accepter aussi leur aide.
Certains amis à moi, ou certains,
ils veulent pas de l'aide
de Feu Vert.
Ils croisent Feu Vert :
"Bonjour, au revoir",
mais ils ont rien à voir
avec Feu Vert.
Quand t'as grandi,
quand on a cet âge-là,
on se dit :
"Ils ont vraiment voulu
nous aider.
On voulait pas, ils ont forcé."
Ils voulaient plus qu'on avance
que nous-même.
-Tire ! Tire !
-OUH !
Brouhaha
...
-Dès qu'ils ont l'amour
de leurs parents,
de la bienveillance
des discours bienveillants
de la part des parents,
même s'ils sont dans une situation
de précarité,
ils auront de la ressource
pour après,
mais s'il y a pas ce minimum-là,
d'amour, de confiance,
et de discours positif,
ça va être compliqué.
-C'est un câlin,
un câlin d'entraide.
Vous voyez comment ?
Limite, c'est comme mon père,
ce type !
Brouhaha
...
Téma ! Téma ! 2 mètres !
Il était avec moi au collège !
Il mange beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup !
C'est mon gars quand même.
Ca, c'est mes frérots, ça.
J'ai fait mon collège avec eux,
et voilà, vous voyez,
un ballon, ça nous suffit pour jouer
et être heureux.
Ils sont là.
Ca c'est mon gars rappeur,
flèche montante, drill.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Voilà !
-Je suis là.
-19e, dis-leur.
Eh ouais !
Là, t'es sur place des Fêtes.
Il y a de tout et il y a de rien,
mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'on est tous là
et on s'en sort tous.
-Tu sais pas qui je suis ?
-C'est carré, alors.
-Je te checke, tu me dis ça.
Frère, tu montes ?
...
Je me suis vraiment amusé
avec Feu Vert.
On a voyagé.
Mes premiers voyages ont été faits
avec Feu Vert, tu vois ?
On partait dans le sud,
dans le nord,
mais c'était toujours des voyages
avec quand même cet aspect
de faire quelque chose en retour.
Quand on partait en voyage,
on se la coulait pas.
On partait,
on ramassait des feuilles,
on travaillait, quoi.
Ils nous apprenaient à travailler.
Tout travail mérite salaire.
J'étais en pro mécanique,
j'ai fait de la pro électronique,
ça m'intéressait pas.
Et il y avait Feu Vert.
Je m'en souviens,
c'était une dame
qui s'appelait Virginie.
Je crois qu'elle travaille
dans le 20e.
Elle m'a aidé de ouf.
A la fin, j'ai eu un entretien
avec le directeur
d'un lycée bac pro vente,
et je suis rentré dedans.
Crescendo, il a kiffé mon profil,
mon potentiel.
S'il y avait pas eu Feu Vert,
j'aurais...
J'aurais peut-être vu
le côté négatif de l'avenir,
l'économie parallèle,
je vais pas te faire de dessin.
Ils ont ce rôle, un peu,
d'éponge, d'écouter,
parce qu'ils sont dans la pédagogie
à fond.
Ils sont là pour les jeunes,
mais pas seulement, Feu Vert.
Ils sont là
pour tout ce qui est paperasse,
si une maman ne parle pas français
ou quoi que ce soit.
Ils sont là vraiment pour aider,
mais ils te donneront jamais
la chose dans ta bouche, tout cru.
Et là,
il est là, le petit binz, tu vois ?
Beaucoup pensent que tu viens
à Feu Vert : "Je veux du travail."
"OK, vas-y, tiens."
Non, non, Ils vont pas te donner.
Ils vont voir si t'es motivé,
ils vont te montrer comment faire.
Il faut avoir
une certaine motivation en soi.
Il faut se faire combat.
*Musique hip-hop
*...
-Ca fait 12 ans, moi,
que je suis sur ce quartier-là.
Je suis sur la 13e année.
Ils le disent, aujourd'hui,
les anciens,
que toi, t'es toujours là.
Tu te dis que tu t'es pas trompé,
parce qu'il y a des moments
difficiles.
Après,
tu peux devenir aussi un petit peu
celui qui porte, un petit peu,
toute la responsabilité
de la frustration.
Certains.
-Pour moi, Himmel,
c'est comme un grand frère,
parce que depuis tout petit,
je le connais.
J'ai confiance en lui,
il a confiance en moi.
Franchement, ouais,
ça peut que être positif.
Ca peut que être positif.
Il me voyait traîner, il disait :
"Va à l'école.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici ?"
Franchement, je lui en veux pas,
je peux que le remercier.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai mon bac.
J'ai eu le diplôme
que ma mère attendait tant.
Franchement,
je peux que le remercier.
Quand ta mère va travailler
tous les jours,
qu'elle est toute seule,
qu'elle travaille,
même quand t'as une basket trouée,
elle va te l'acheter,
tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Franchement, aujourd'hui,
je peux que remercier ma mère.
Je peux que remercier ma mère,
parce que sans elle,
je serais pas ce que je suis
aujourd'hui.
Sans elle, je serais pas...
Franchement, c'est...
C'est compliqué.
C'est vrai que ça a été compliqué
de la voir aller travailler.
Moi aussi, j'essaye de travailler
pour que mes enfants
soient au maximum,
pour que mes descendants,
comme on dit,
ils soient au top.
-Nous, on est là,
on est en bas tous les jours,
on voit tous les jours
la même chose,
mais Himmel nous fait découvrir
les environs.
Je sais pas, chez moi,
ça existe pas, ça.
Une activité, au karting,
en famille, et tout,
ma mère a d'autres chats à fouetter.
On a fait du vélo,
on a fait du kayak,
trop de trucs, avec Himmel,
trop de trucs, trop de trucs,
j'ai fait trop de trucs,
trop d'activités.
J'ai fait du paintball,
j'ai fait du karting...
Là, aujourd'hui,
je suis animateur.
De base,
il m'a trouvé juste un truc,
juste pour avoir un peu d'argent,
histoire d'avoir un peu
d'argent de poche.
Grâce à lui, aujourd'hui,
ils ont kiffé mon travail,
ils m'ont donné
plusieurs responsabilités,
je gagne même plus
le salaire du début.
Musique planante
...
-Ca fait longtemps
que je t'ai pas vu !
On a acheté de la viande !
-Arrête de mentir.
Toi, t'as maigri !
Rires
T'es tout maigre, mon frère.
-Ca va ? Tranquille ?
-Il arrive de Turquie.
Les loukoums, et tout...
Ah, attention, c'est gênant, là.
Rires
Un petit cadeau.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
Je vais le montrer un petit peu.
Il est parti en vacances,
il m'a ramené un petit cadeau.
Je l'ouvrirai tranquillement.
Rires
-C'est plutôt au collège,
où ça a commencé.
C'est souvent au collège,
à tous les sens,
où on veut s'affirmer.
On rencontre des gens,
on se fait tous influencer
par les plus grands
qui sont nos modèles.
Au quartier, les potes, en tout cas,
les modèles qu'on voyait,
c'était plutôt des grands
avec des belles voitures.
C'était plutôt ça.
Après, on rencontre,
on est une bande,
tout le monde se...
J'ai suivi. J'ai suivi.
J'ai suivi mes copains.
En fait, c'est ça.
Et puis après, au quartier,
ça continuait.
On a commencé à vendre
un peu de shit, voilà,
et puis voilà.
L'influence, c'est très important.
Ils m'ont influencé.
-C'est pas vrai ! Il m'a influencé.
-Pas lui.
-Elle est arrivé au moment
où on commençait...
-On avait des gros problèmes.
-Nos problèmes
étaient énormes comme ça.
Musique planante
...
-Ce que j'ai adoré, à l'époque,
chez Feu Vert, c'est le fait
qu'ils ne portent pas de jugement.
Je les avais rencontrés,
ils étaient trois.
Il y en a trois qui m'ont marqué,
avec qui on a beaucoup échangé,
qui nous écoutaient, sans jugement.
Je m'en rappelle,
j'avais intégré une école,
un lycée technique
dans le 11e.
C'était grâce à Nassira.
On était là, assis,
j'arrive avec des numéros,
j'ose pas appeler,
parce que c'était une école
dans le 11e.
Pour moi, le 11e, quartiers chics,
j'y allais que la nuit.
Nassira, elle appelle,
je sais pas comment elle a fait,
elle a réussi à convaincre
la directrice un rendez-vous.
Elle me dit : "Vas-y."
Je dis : "Comment ça ?"
"Vas-y, t'inquiète pas."
Elle appelle, j'ai mon rendez-vous,
j'y vais, et ça a matché.
Ils voient que notre projet,
on y tient à coeur,
ils vont nous aider,
ils vont pas nous lâcher.
Ils nous lâchent pas.
Quand on a envie de lâcher,
ils disent :
"Lâche pas.
J'ai confiance en toi."
Rien que le fait de dire :
"J'ai confiance en toi", voilà.
Pour ma part,
c'est ce qu'ils m'ont apporté,
le fait de savoir que moi aussi,
je pouvais le faire.
Elle a fait partie de ma vie,
elle m'a aidé.
Et surtout,
aujourd'hui, comme j'ai dit,
je suis ingénieur automaticien,
et c'est elle.
-C'est ma deuxième maman.
Un jour, je me souviens,
on était dans ma voiture
ou dans sa voiture,
j'ai dit : "J'ai ma maman chez moi
et j'ai ma maman de dehors."
Elle me dit : "C'est qui ?"
J'ai dit : "C'est toi."
Quand c'est pas elle
qui me prend la tête, c'est toi.
Donc ouais.
En fait, je pourrais pas expliquer.
C'est...
Je sais pas, on ressent les choses.
Je voyais
beaucoup de sincérité chez elle.
Le fait qu'elle soit aussi sensible
à l'art,
je crois que c'est ça qui a fait...
Je pense que...
comme ils ont pris leur travail
au sérieux,
nous aussi,
on les a pris au sérieux,
et oui, ça a sauvé
beaucoup de personnes.
Même si parfois,
on se voyait pas
pendant un laps de temps,
on avait toujours une pensée
pour Feu Vert.
Je pense qu'indirectement,
ces éducateurs, ces sorciers, là,
indirectement,
ils nous ont donné ce truc-là,
en nous, qui...
On va dire, on a envie d'aider
les plus jeunes, automatiquement.
Là, ce qui va se passer,
c'est que là,
c'est le dernier artiste.
Je sais pas si vous connaissez.
*Musique hip-hop
*...
Acclamations
*Musique pop
*...
-Je peux dire une phrase ?
Pensez beaucoup à la vie.
Sans ça, t'es rien.
Musique douce
-Tiens, allez.
-D'accord, merci.
-Là, ça a filmé.
T'envoies à tes enfants.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA